this video is presented by tales of
arise
as fancy rpgs go very few have the
legacy of the tales of series with over
25 years and 16 main titles already
secured in both the hearts and gaming
collections of fans now with tales of a
rise not only are we going to be treated
to a new and masterfully crafted action
adventure rpg but a fully enhanced tales
of experience from the combat to the
characters and the entire world design
these exciting new changes and
improvements have so much to offer new
players and long time fans so whichever
camp you hail from let's take a look at
what you can expect from tales of arise
let's start with combat what's a quest
to challenge the fate of civilization
without a good kicking to the bad guys
the battle system has been enriched from
previous games in the series with combat
feeling fast and frenetic
fights take place in a closed 3d area
after an encounter giving you and the
team plenty of space to maneuver and
plan your attack
during the fight you'll control one of
the six main characters from your
adventure with three others making up
your team of four
each has their own strengths combat
style and perks that can wildly swing
the tide of battle so if you pride
yourself on the efficient slapping of
your enemies there's a lot of detail to
get into if you choose
your two protagonists alfin and shion
both have some awesome moves
alfin is a sword-wielding all-rounder
while xion sports a rifle that is great
against aerial enemies the rest of your
party is no different
lore is a hand-to-hand combat pro that
dominates rigid and armored enemies
rinwell is your magic user who also
pairs great against other magic users
kisara and her shield work well with
charging enemies and also protecting
allies while dohalin is ideal for
getting the nippy agile enemies with his
combat rod
the best part of the combat entails of
her eyes is seeing the team working
together in a seamless unit lighting up
the arena with dramatic combos and
special attacks that overwhelm your
enemies and leave you with a smug look
and a fistful of loot for your trouble
as with previous tales games there are
several ways to deal damage in a fight
your basic attack is free to use any
time and ideal to start getting early
hits on your combo counter
you can target weak points on certain
enemies to increase your chance of
breaking their guard and knocking them
down opening up a window for you and the
team to lay it on thick
next you have special techniques known
in the series as arts these are mapped
to three of your face buttons but
require charge from your arts gauge you
can see this just above your hp gauge
each art uses a particular amount of aeg
to perform so you can choose if you want
to save up for a bigger move or hammer
through cheaper attacks some arts will
even launch your enemies opening them up
to additional attacks in the air this
also changes your available arts from
ground to aerial giving you a total of
six to work with
as the game progresses you'll not only
unlock more arts and skills but also the
ability to use more than six in combat
of course getting damage in is all well
and good
great even
really great but unless you know how to
avoid it yourself these fights are going
to be short and painful with the
exception of kisara and her enormous
shield the other five characters can't
block attacks instead you'll be dodging
you can dodge in any direction you
choose but timing it just right will
give you a perfect dodge opening up a
window to counter attack your enemy
mastery of this is key to maintaining
the flow in battle and keeping the
pressure on so take some time early on
to get a feel for the movement future
you will thank you if you do take some
damage you can use healing and support
arts to recover your hp
beware though this uses up cure points
or cp that can usually only be recovered
from resting out of combat so avoiding
damage is always preferable
next you have your boost attacks you can
see each character charging their boost
gauge over their icon in the lower left
corner
as the team leader you can choose when
to trigger these by pressing the
corresponding button on the d-pad these
are powerful moves unique to each
character and have some handy special
effects
alfin for example can use some of his
own hp to do bonus damage while xi'an
can knock flying enemies out of the sky
but what if the boost attack you need
isn't in the active party
worry not you can still call in that
ally to jump in and perform the move
as you get more comfortable with the
battle system you'll master the timing
of boost attacks to give the maximum
impact for you and the team
where things get really dramatic are
with boost strikes
as you lay the damage on an enemy you'll
be building up its strike gauge
if it fills you'll get an on-screen
prompt to hit the d-pad and watch the
screen light up as two characters team
up to smash a boss or finish off lighter
foe
this is by far the most satisfying way
to end a fight and will contribute to
your battle score at the end the better
your score the more skill points you'll
get for upgrading your skills and titles
throughout the game
on rare occasions you'll also get the
strike prompt when certain conditions
are met so watch out for these
opportunities to see your teammates in
action doing their finest work
[Music]
now that you've got combat sorted let's
take a look at the stunning worlds
you'll be exploring on your adventure
welcome to the breathtaking landscapes
of dana and rena
tales of arise has a whole new look from
previous games in the series giving the
environment incredible scale and detail
using the atmospheric shader
the traditional anime look has been
modernized but longtime fans will still
recognize the style especially during
the skits and fully animated cut scenes
within the game
well this crew just gets bigger and
bigger tales of arise takes place across
multiple regions of two different worlds
the more medieval world of dana and the
advanced world of rena
renner has ruled over dana for 300 years
enslaving its people and soaking up
dana's resources for themselves now
divided up by walls and controlling
lords you and the party will have a huge
variety of regions to explore
from the dry desert regions of calaglia
dotted with oil refining machinery
to the snow-covered region of siselodia
each with unique characters to meet on
your quest
the region's a semi-open world meaning
you'll be moving through several smaller
open areas that aren't directly
connected to one another
fans of tales games will know all too
well that curiosity is often rewarded in
these areas so be sure to really take a
look around for resources and hidden
secrets
new to tales of arise is the ability to
jump over the terrain and swim in
shallow water opening up new options and
opportunities in the game
for newcomers you'll be glad to know
that you can keep your distance from
enemies you don't want to engage meaning
you'll always be ready for your next
fight
in the open world you'll want to make
sure you're managing your health and
cure points
out of combat it's usually best to heal
up using items such as gels rather than
burning through your cp as this precious
resource is also needed to unlock closed
paths to progress the game
and find hidden treasures
wow
you can rest up at campsites to recover
cp as well as engage in a bit of
delicious cooking
recipes will need different ingredients
of course but the bonus effects can help
you and the team both in and out of
combat so it's well worth dusting off
the old apron for good this came out
just the way i hoped you can even take
on farming of animals and crops as well
as fishing to help out with your
resource management
you'll also be coming across npcs out in
the wild and entire communities in the
towns
here you can trade items and resources
upgrade your gear and forge brand new
weapons to take into battle
each character has a main weapon armor
set and an accessory that you'll be
changing up as you go
your cosmetic style isn't directly tied
to your equipment though
costumes are a recurring feature in the
tails games freeing you up to craft your
own look with your favorite gear
speaking of which keep an eye out in the
world as you might spot an owl sitting
quietly by itself
go say hello and you'll be rewarded with
an interesting equippable item
as the characters in the game are now 3d
models rather than illustrations you'll
be able to see them in their costumes
during moments of dialogue
tails games have always put story and
character connections first and tales of
her eyes is no different
the relationship between the two
protagonists alfin and shion is
particularly difficult with alfin at
and shion are renin
[Music]
alfin has no memory of his past but is
driven by a desire to free his people
from the grasp of rena
as well as losing his memory he's also
lost the ability to feel pain
the somewhat handy trick that motivates
his hp sapping arts in combat
xi'an has allied herself with alfin
against her own people but is afflicted
with the curse of thorns hurting anyone
who touches her as a renin shion is also
able to draw and use astral energy a
power that resides in all living things
and use it in the form of astral arts
she's able to manifest this energy into
the blazing sword a weapon that burns
whoever wields it with alfin's ability
to withstand pain he becomes the only
person capable of grasping the sword but
also capable of any physical connection
with xion making their relationship all
the more complex
[Music]
as you explore the landscape you'll
quickly meet the rest of your allies and
begin forging the bonds that drive the
story of tales of arise for new players
you'll find a deep and engaging action
rpg with exciting combat and a rich
world to explore
for fans so much will feel familiar as
this much love series gets the enhanced
and modernized touches it deserves
tales of arise launches on september
10th ready for you to challenge the fate
of a world
[Music]
alfie
[Music]
[Applause]